tu t'es jamais demandé ce qu'il ya au
dehors
il ya des merveilles en ce monde
parent devient de contrer
je sens
toutes les nuits
je fais le même rêve
hélas
le cauchemar commence
j'ai fait ce que je devais faire
pour protéger notre monde vous ne pouvez
pas tout contrôler et strange
vous savez ouvert le portail qui relie
des souffert et nous signerons qu'elle
sait trop quelle chose dont le franchir
que savez vous du multivers vision avait
une théorie
il pensait que c'était dangereux
il avait raison
je suis neuf estivale
la profanation de la réalité
restera pas impuni
[Musique]
nous devrions lui dire la vérité
les choses viennent de t'échapper
[Musique]
renier les règles
et vous devenez un héros
quand je le fais je deviens l'ennemi
je trouve pas ça normal
[Musique]
c'est
je suis censé rencontrer un homme
qui doit l'emmener au camp de travail
ctt
je viens de l'ouest c'est ça avec les
choses qu'on peut très bien dans ce
coin-là
gens se battre entre eux
mais pourquoi et quand tu travailles
c'est bizarre comme destination c'est
censé être une occasion unique
qu'est ce qu'il vient me rejoindre viens
voir ça
c'est vraiment de l'or on a prouvé dès 8
ans
nous deux va devoir aller chercher une
excavatrice pour la sortir
je crois que je vais rester avec l'art
il faut surveiller son nom faut se
protéger du soleil et c'est pas une
partie de plaisir par ici
encore combien de temps que je peux
alors tu es tout seul ici faut que tu
t'en al
amal à la terre ont tout va commencer à
te sembler étrange
ceux qui doutent qu'elle a bu lors tu
cache quelque chose d'appris mois dans
l'attentât je suis tout près j'ai plus
ma part c'était moi je me fous
ces bretons ja
je me débrouillais
servives pas à distinguer fille
mais rêve
de la réalité
ça doit être pénible toutes ces voix
dans ta tête
il ya du désordre endroit
accepte le
le bal costumé des monstres ma famille
va adorer
je vous ordonne d'envoûter cette femme
et de la transformer en vampire
pourquoi on est les seules personnes à
porter des déguisements rabastens
trois minutes ce soit génial en plus
maintenant il va se mettre dedans
je suis une horrible sorcière j'ai des
poils sur tout le corps pourquoi ces
bandages sont collés pas à
c'est bien parti
je suis là par ont immortalisé johnny d
hymne au
maine mois gel maintenant c'est à moi de
prendre le relais les créatures à quatre
pattes doivent être tenus en laisse à
quatre pattes vous dis
je suis l'affairé de carrière
on va retrouver la sorcière et elle va
nous rendre notre appartement qu en
famille le
mais toute la famille à trappes
je vous présente le super joueur dont je
vous ai parlé selim
[Musique]
les crevettes les crevasses privant les
crevettes le meilleur c'est la tête la
tête et avec les paillettes c'est
mouillé à ccc la fête à la mer merci
damien
bkt laquelle
je n'étais pas qu'on dirait tout bégué
c'est un peu le concept de l'équipe
et moi tu m'as fait et on n'est pas là
pour soi ça clients on va faire comment
pour gagner des matches
tu as bien dit que l'ambiance est gay
c'est juste une équipe de water polo en
transit pour tokyo sans aucune intention
de nuire à votre pays ici l'homophobie
c'est un sport national on se met en
mode furtif d'accord quelle chance
d'être nés avec si peu de couilles
avec ça mais on est tombé dans un
guet-apens
ligue 1
vous les avez arrêté parce qu'ils sont
gays encore fait n'importe quoi je my
own attends attends mon tour de
vous
co-skipper de nous
qu'est ce qui est si anormal à ce que
deux personnes du même sexe m
physiquement j'ai jamais demandé
différent j'ai entrepris mois de cette
obsession crie sa différence alors que
tout ce qu'on veut c'est comme tout le
monde si on a pu avoir des enfants si on
a pu se marier c'est grâce à des gens
comme eux qui combattent depuis des
années l'homophobie à grands coups de
talons aiguilles et de gay pride on est
les cravates ont les ronald on les a
sauvés et tu comptes faire quoi à la
mairie
[Musique]
dans ce faire on va crever c'est bien
moi je vous dis
[Musique]
c'est quoi ça c'est un game of home
mais pas james bond qui pourtant est gay
james bond il épinglait excuse moi mais
bale c'est tout le monde le sait un peu
non de toute façon avec vous tout le
monde est gay bah oui
[Musique]
hollywood est vérité
sic et adq rangers du risque la série de
toute une génération qui a transformé
deux écureuils inconnu en superstar
internationale
mais tandis que le succès propulse
étiquette accueillir de nouveaux sommets
à plat de nouvelle saison des rangers du
risque on était sur un petit nuage on
danse elle roger rabbit avec roger
rabbit
personne n'imaginait
que tout pourrait s'effondrer
détruit par la vanité tu as l'air
différent et tout le monde sait que je
me suis fait refaire en 3d et bord et
par la tentation mon amour du fromage a
perdu je fume on
est une possible que le destin
réunissent tous légende vivante
[Applaudissements]
je pense un reboot personnes venaient à
reebok
les randonnées un déguisement attrape le
premier truc que tu trouveras
sérieux
[Musique]
ouais
génial
tu risques 2.0
m
[Musique]
cet endroit est bizarre tu te rappelles
ce style d'animation où tout avait l'air
réel mais où rien n'était réaliste qu
elle vous fait à nouveau parler c'est
évident non parce qu'on dirait vous
parlez à 7,9 non on dirait que c'est
vous que je regarde on le gardait mes
yeux qui regardent droit dans vos yeux
ouais
[Musique]
j'arrive toujours pas à croire qu'ils
aient changé la date de leur mariage à
la dernière on trouvera quand même un
moyen de célébrer son anniversaire je
crois que je fais vieille alors tu es
superbe tué six
[Musique]
chiens non merci non elle boit pas
d'alcool elle en a jamais vu dit marie
avec un homme qui a d'un bois
isaac vient au mariage dans l'embauché
mon ex petit ami pour démolir notre
maison familiale ça sonne plutôt mal
quand tu le dis comme ça
[Musique]
ralenti
mais tu entends pas ou quoi je n'étais
pas te crier de ralentir judée dole et
les angoisses tort à de boire maintenant
je me sens mal priam inapte alcan a lieu
au moins ils ont la passion
de clémence ne veut plus que tu viennes
au mariage quoi je sens que ton énergie
et toxines et je veux pas de ça prenne
mois pour le jour le plus important de
ma vie c'est toi qui a une énergie
toxiques tu es méchante il veut tout
contrôler totalement égocentrée
[Rires]
tu es toujours aussi belle nous c'est
pas vrai ou dallas je rêve
d'un passé la soirée avec ton petit ami
ne suis perdu dans cette fausse réalité
je voulais juste me sortir jeunes et
nouveaux qu'est ce qu'il ya de si génial
à être jeune en fait tu fais des choses
du vide et du prend de mauvaises
décisions
[Musique]
mon frère a toujours eu des goûts très
difficile et très raffiné alors je suis
sûr que tu es une personne merveilleuse
et j'ai vraiment hâte m
en italie
je vais remettre est cool en place c'est
pas dangereux
c'est ce qu'ils édictent faire du mal je
suis vraiment ému sortie